five four three two one and liftoff of
the space shuttle Discovery with the
Hubble Space Telescope our window on the
universe Hubble is the first major
optical telescope sent into space taking
images from above the distortion of the
atmosphere and light pollution nASA has
called it the ultimate mountaintop when
the possibility of a telescope in space
opened up
astronomers jumped on the idea
scientists have used Hubble to observe
the most distant stars and galaxies as
well as the planets in our solar system
it's most famous photo was taken in 1995
a so-called Deep Field image showing
areas of the universe as they were
billions of years ago during three
decades in orbit Hubble has influenced
many people back on earth it's my job to
make things up for a living and
constantly use my imagination but Hubble
and the dedicated scientists behind it
take all of that a step further I've
been fortunate to work on shows like the
Orville battlestar galactica I spent
almost two decades on Star Trek our
space is kind of my game but you know
when you look at the vistas that have
been gifted to us by Hubble it changes
not just your mind but it changes your
DNA Hubble orbits the earth once every
hour and a half giving us a great
witness in space Hubble was also the
first telescope designed to be visited
in space so astronauts could carry out
repairs but early in its mission
engineers found a problem that shocked
them the images sent back to earth were
blurred a lot of people feel we don't
need the Star Wars defense system
anymore hey I think we should keep it
you know if only to shoot down that
Hubble spacecraft put this thing out of
its misery
after twelve years of construction at a
cost of billions of dollars astronauts
were sent to space in 1993 to fix the
faulty lens that mission was a success
and fantastic images began to be
transmitted back to earth when people
talk about the legacy of Hubble I I
think among its greatest legacies will
be helping humanity understand that yeah
when things go to space we can in fact
they're not it's not hopeless if there's
something wrong we can service them in
in many cases if we make some
preparation to do that but Hubble does
have an expiry date scientists estimate
it should last another five years or
until its solar batteries stopped
working until then Hubble can build on
its legacy revealing yet more images
from far depths of our universe Lea
Harding al-jazeera